aux grandes marées de septembre les
pêcheurs à pied se comptent par
centaines sur les îles de sur les îles
chausey pardon au large de granville
c'est justement pour protéger un tel
site du tourisme de masse que la
directive européenne natura 2000 est
entrée en vigueur une directive qui ne
fait pas toujours l'unanimité voyez ce
reportage de loïc le moigne et jean-yves
ses rangs sur le quai de choses et une
jeune femme discrète dans les manches de
son ciré elle cache des boules de
contact depuis juillet tous les
touristes qui on met les pieds sur l'île
ont été comptés un parent choses et au
large du mont saint michel le plus grand
archipel d'europe 5000 hectares de grève
à marée basse
certains jours on compte plus d'un
millier de pêcheurs à pied notamment aux
grandes marées de septembre la ressource
semble inépuisable
depuis trois ans l'état veut appliquer
la directive européenne natura 2000 pour
protéger faune et flore et réglementer
la pêche
mais les opposants à cette nouvelle
réglementation ont réuni quatorze mille
signatures
nous avons peur que sous prétexte que
l'on veut protéger les oiseaux les
amines les animaux et les habitats que
l'homme lui soit complètement évincé
qu'on mette choses et sous cloche et que
nous on nous retire alors qu'en fait les
nous aussi nous faisons partie de
l'environnement de choses et stéphane
renard est chargé de mettre en place
natura 2000 à choses et l'université de
brest et de conservatoire du littoral
dhr est actuellement un état des lieux
de l'archipel mais pas question
d'évoquer trop tôt d'éventuelles
interdictions stéphane renard veut
avancer prudemment sur ce dossier
brûlant
il n'y a pas de limite théorique une
présentation sur un site quel qu'il soit
c'est simplement assuré que cette
fréquentation n'est d'ailleurs pas le
milieu ne donne pas non plus le
sentiment
aux personnes qui viennent aux
discussions et aux autres que ceux cités
sur fréquenté ou dénaturer pour les
pêcheurs professionnels le projet est
encore dans le brouillard
combien de mouillage seront conservés
quelles zones seront interdites à la
pêche
ils craignent qu'une réglementation de
type parc national une un parc national
qui était pourtant à port cros est ce
qu'ils ont fait ils ont qu un quart des
personnes de travailler ils ont réduit
tellement la surface de terrains
exploitables que les gants sont partis
d'eux-mêmes
devant les réticences l'état fait marche
arrière
aujourd'hui il se donne du temps pour
réfléchir à d'autres mesures
parmi les pistes de réflexion la
limitation du nombre de passagers sur
les vedettes dans les années à venir il
pourrait y avoir moins de monde sur
laquelle de choses et